good morning believe nation today's
messages stand by your word over to you
master P you know also what I learned in
business just like what she was saying
when you give somebody your word your
word is so important once I gave her my
word I had to come even I I've got a
million other things I got to do is say
well I gave up my word and that's gonna
go a long way with you in business once
you give somebody your word it's good to
get it and write everything that you
need to get done but when you give
somebody your word you got to stand by
because when you start standing by your
word you'll be able to build more
relationships and resources when I took
over Kannada and salsa
I hired Alex away from a steady stable
safe secure job we had a number of
meetings talking about the opportunity
and the the message that I repeated over
and over to him and I've continued to
repeat with my team is I will not always
give you the answer that you want to
hear but I'll give you the truth I'll
give you the honest answer you want to
know something ask me and I'll give you
the truth and when I say that I'm gonna
do something I'm gonna do it for you and
it's easy to say because I think a lot
of people say that the trick is to
quickly back it up the to quickly find
ways to take action on what you say
you're gonna do and if you ask Alex one
of the things he told me was you know I
talked a big game and he really liked it
he felt like if I deliver it on half the
things that we talked about he would be
better off and it's only through my
action that he realized that I meant
everything that I said and really deeply
truly meaningfully cared for not only a
business success but his success as a
human being you know within the company
in his relationships his personal growth
it all matters to me and I told him that
and and they think he kind of understood
it but it was through the action
he really deeply understood it for me
team building is such an important thing
and relationships are such an important
thing when I work with somebody I want
it to be for life like if they want to
leave to move on to their own thing
that's great if I can't provide them
with the opportunity that's great but I
I have the intent in every relationship
that I enter into for it to be for life
as long as you're growing and I want to
help you get there let's keep working
together and so for that to work there
has to be a lot of honesty and trust
both ways right
I am very accepting and trusting of
other people's words until they give me
a reason not to be there's a lot of
people in my business that I don't have
written contracts with because for me a
handshake is a written contract for me
if I shake your hand on something I will
follow through on it it's just as
critical as getting the written down and
so I encourage you to take that approach
it builds your own self-worth too it
builds your own self confidence the self
esteem - when you tell somebody you're
gonna do it to actually follow through
and do it like stop not following
through stop breaking your work because
when you break your word to yourself you
can't become the best version of you
you'll stop pursuing your goals or stop
chasing big things because you
continually break promises to yourself
so take your word as the gospel take
your word as something that you will not
break and the next step at least for me
is try to take some kind of immediate
action to build momentum for yourself on
your own goals as well as for other
people when you commit to them don't
wait till next week to get started on it
do one small thing right now and build
immediate momentum so that you can get
closer to your goal so the question that
today is I'm curious how much of you
guys insist on getting stuff down in
writing before getting into an
arrangement with somebody I'm really
curious leave on the comments below I'm
gonna join the discussion thank you guys
so much for watching have an amazing day
continue to believe and I'll see you
again tomorrow morning for another shot
I've been specified
we go